[Musique]
des chèvres et autres animaux de la
ferme au coeur du quartier saint louis
le spectacle aura de quoi surprendre
mais les visiteurs sont bien habitués
cela fait dix ans qu'ils esprit jardin
réunit les passionnés de jardinage dans
la cité royale
on était déjà venu l'année dernière
c'est on prend du bon temps il fait très
beau il ya du soleil et puis ça permet
de faire découvrir aux enfants les
plantes et puis et puis on profite des
animaux de la ferme qui sont juste à
côté
depuis trois ans oui qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît dans les airs
l'ambiance les fleurs les stands et
qu'il renouvellement tous les ans sur
les décorations comme sophie plus de
25000 visiteurs sont venus craqué sur
les végétaux et découvrir les nouveautés
de cette 10e édition pour la première
fois les curieux ont pu se promener dans
le jardin de la cathédrale saint-louis
jusque là fermé au public
on avait envie de faire découvrir aux
gens ce petit jardin de la cathédrale au
petit jardin du presbytère qui a une qui
est tout à fait charmant et surtout qui
fait un peu comme on dirait jardin
secret on est dans un patrimoine
historique de la ville de versailles et
dans le saint louis qui est vraiment le
quartier le plus ancien de versailles du
parvis de la cathédrale jusqu'au potager
du roi un événement qui rend aussi
hommage au patrimoine végétal de la
ville un héritage dont andré le nôtre et
jean baptiste de la quintinie ont
construit la renommée